let me just make absolutely sure I'm
allowed to do this
public. Cool. So, I never stream client
work. Um, because
client work is typically closed source.
I build custom sims. Uh, this client
decided to open source the sim. So, that
means there's no reason I can't do the
development for it live, which I figure
would be pretty cool. Um, and also I'm
sort of towards the end of this chunk of
the project and it's starting to drag
just a little bit. You know, there's a
lot of debugging and testing that I got
to do. So, I figured it would be fun and
probably more productive to do it on
stream. Uh, I don't feel like I'm
missing stream hours and client gets
their work done faster. Everybody wins.
I've got um I don't know a good couple
hours two two and a half hours now to
get a little bit of stuff done on this.
Let me tell you what this environment is
about.
So
um this is a commerce environment
uh in which we are simulating buying and
selling compute from data centers
and then there's like negotiation of
prices and I mean this is going to
actually be used right so real world end
not everything is robotics right you can
use RL on a ton of different problems
and I fig we do a little bit of dev on
this thing. It's a massive cup.
Honestly,
I feel like I could use a way bigger
one.
The recipe for that is uh it's a 66 g of
protein mug of hot chocolate. That's
what that is.
welcome YouTube folks.
So, we do some real dev today.
Unfortunately, the real dev is mostly
going to be cleaning up and testing this
environment, but I think it'll still be
pretty interesting to watch.
Yeah. So, this is the initial test that
we have.
We pretty much just have like this
specification loaded in
and we're going to be attempting to map
uh specific
specific outputs.
So,
energy expense. Let's see if we can get
this to be a predictable number.
Check some pull request. I really
should, but I also have to get some
client work done.
Um,
I have the thing is I have this client
job. It was supposed to be done before
the holidays, but then some stuff
happened. So, I've been just needing to
catch this one up. And then I have one
more that we signed that we need to get
started on. That one can't be streamed.
So, I'd like to at least get this chunk
done and then I can catch up on my other
stuff. I have a ton of different plates
spinning. Uh I know like there are some
pretty major fixes that have been PR as
well as a couple really awesome
environments like Overcooked. Um I I'm
going to merge all of that stuff. It's
just there's a lot to do lately
started for ArcGI 3. I'll be surprised
if that works. Frankly, the pattern
recognition of portion of that is not
learnable within the environment itself.
How long I've been working on this on
this client and
I can't tell you when we sign a few
months.
I can say a few months.
Anyways,
uh yes, this revenue number, we want
this number to be something predictable,
right? So,
oh, there's a formula for this, right?
Because it should be
like $10
times.
Hang on. So, it's 90 steps. Wait, is
this even remotely close?
No, it's off by a factor of two, isn't
it?
node comp. Oh, wait. It doesn't have
100. Huh?
I'm confused.
We want to get this to be a predictable
number. And then we want to have a few
different specs that match
uh
job TB usage.
Make sure we're not counting terabytes.
Uh okay. So that gets us perfectly to
uh this is still double the number I
would expect, right?
Wait, should it not just be
times
No, because it's in hours, right? So
it's one node.
Where's the 8 the other $800 coming
from?
Okay, so this is what we're expecting,
right? Look, we get $10 of revenue per
tick
and somehow we have 1,800.
Um Oh, I think we're counting it twice,
right? Yeah, we're double counting.
Okay, so we have to figure this one out
then because
this was actually a genuine modeling
difficulty. So the question was right,
you have this on demand,
you've got this on demand compute and
when do you recognize the profits,
right? Do you treat it like an account
that just ticks down and it's paid for
per hour or do you treat it as a
reservation?
bucks of revenue.
That's what we like.
I'm just going to do this because I
think we're going to end up with a few
different types of these.
Well,
I believe this is 200 steps.
Yeah. So first of all, why is it 200
steps?
Not 200 steps. Okay. Interesting.
All right, let's figure out why the heck
it's 500 steps. And then I think what
we're going to end up doing,
we're going to just write some actual
automated tests on this thing.
It'll be nice.
I don't actually typically have to do
this with M um all that often. It's very
very important for like
difficult to verify M essentially stuff
that's um not like obvious from the
visuals if it's correct or not. It's one
of the reasons we like games so much in
RL.
Yeah, it repeats each take five.
So, let's see why.
So, we have this like negotiation thing.
Uh yeah, we have this negotiation thing
where if you're negotiating it doesn't
actually increase time
negotiations. Okay. So where does tick
get incremented
here?
Okay. So, we are we are stuck here.
Response price.
Ah, okay. I see what's happening here.
So, what's happening is um the cluster
is out of capacity.
So
yeah, the cluster doesn't have any more
capacity left
because it takes the job. Um,
but then there's another job that comes
up into the queue
and
everything gets protracted because of
that. So let me think what we do about
that. What's the desired behavior here?
I think that what we do is just as an
optimization.
Um if there is no agent that can accept
the job
then uh we do not trigger negotiation
phase. That will be better.
That's kind of messy, but I think that
works for now, right?
No more opus. I don't need it for what
I'm doing right now, do I?
Like I said, when I write that, like I
got to just write that article,
otherwise people are going to get the
wrong idea. Like that might have made me
5x faster for chunks of stuff that I was
doing when I have CUDA kernels that are
bound to torch that are redundantly
bound to Python that also have to fit
the C++ API. like there's a ton a ton of
redundancy and it's very fiddly and
nothing is well documented and it's also
very precise but it's also very
verifiable.
I mean, I could probably use it and it
would probably make me a little bit more
productive maybe, but I'd also have to
like it would be about the same amount
of effort to make sure it doesn't go off
the rails.
I still have to write the article and
there's just a bunch of client work and
other stuff I got to do. Are we off by
one tick?
Yeah, we're off by one tick.
So, it should be
Okay,
here's our test.
And we need a few more tests.
Uh, this is a client end of FBR. The
reason I'm deving it is I realized, wait
a second. Um, I don't have to spend like
a few hours, like several times a week
doing this off stream because it's
actually open source anyways. So, I
figured I'd be more productive doing it
on stream and I'd get my streaming hours
in, too.
Plus, we send over a couple people to
look at the cool stuff they're doing
because this is a pretty interesting
commerce and
it models um cloud purchasing
and people also keep asking like what I
do professionally, right? So, this is
what we do. It's pretty much the same
thing. We build M's. Um but then the M's
are just for various applications.
Mhm.
Let me think what we do with this.
Oh yeah, and if you're uh you guys are
interested in this as well, you can go
follow um let me find the guy.
He just made a an ex account for the
You can go check this stuff out over
here.
Okay. So, these curves
I'd like to have the energy demand be
predictable here. So let's do
Yeah, that's kind of gross, isn't it?
Um,
right. This was just like uh Taylor
uh not Taylor Forier expansion.
I can set all these. Let's here. Hang
on.
We're going to try to come up with like
a predictable for you series.
So what this is um the guy wanted a very
configurable way to specify uh functions
that model energy pricing.
So I went okay I have no idea how to do
that other than just like letting you
write an arbitrary piece of code but
you're going to want to write Python and
I have C. So like you know what here
have the first have the first three 4A
components [laughter]
there. Model whatever you want.
A 4A series is um wave expansion. And
you can use it to model well any
function but way more realistically any
sort of very periodic function with uh
not too many components. You add a few
signs and cosiness together and you get
something that looks a lot like your
function quite quickly.
and remove this bot.
Hey, user.
Welcome.
Nice.
All right. Why do we still have energy
revenue?
How do we possibly still have
energy revenue
and energy expense
Okay, that's better. So, now what we're
going to do, right, is
use the FFT.
Yeah, it's everybody's favorite thing.
It's cool, but it only comes up in like
specific applications
uh reasonably often, right?
we have,00 00 job revenue. That's weird.
Look at that.
How did that happen?
You see 1,100 job revenue. That's bad.
Oh, I bet you the agent just doesn't get
reset, right?
We reset.
Yeah. You see there's one extra step.
Oh, because it doesn't end. Dub. Okay.
So,
people gather to share. Is there some
place? Yeah, discord.gg/puffer.
We have probably the biggest Discord in
the space. It's all open source.
What's the agent learning this end? Um,
they're a couple different agents.
They're learning how to buy and sell
compute though.
And again, these guys are right here if
you want to check out their stuff.
So, let me think what we should be doing
on reset. Um,
actually, we can totally just return
from this, can't we?
I think we can literally just do this
and we're good.
Yeah, there we go. Now we pass our test.
Negotiations. Negotiations. We're
simulating. Yeah. So the one thing
that's a little bit janky about that is
um
you have to just not advance the time
step and
essentially give the agents multiple
steps of back and forth uh in which they
can propose new prices which will sort
of mess up the credit assignment horizon
a little bit
but hopefully not too bad. We'll see.
Okay, this is our first test pass
though. So, I'm going to use the rest
room. And then we're going to go uh add
a bunch more of these. And the idea here
is going to be that we just put a bunch
of different scenarios in here. We
essentially load in different scenarios
and we make sure that uh the expected
behavior is what we see. And then this
will have this will give us a lot of
confidence that the sim is fully
correct. We'll probably fix a bunch of
bugs in the process because this was a
big update to it. And then uh we'll get
training some agents
and I will leave uh their Twitter page
up in the meanwhile so you can follow
them here while I use the restroom.
Right back
Okay.
Time step only advances if there's a buy
or sells. Uh, at the moment
it's not quite going to be that. Okay.
Um, because there's also
it's either if there's a buy or sell or
if it's impossible to fill an order.
There's also a timeout on negotiation.
So there are a few different conditions
that can advance the uh the buy or sell
state.
Like I said 24 the article will be there
when I write it.
I have lots of stuff to do.
Probably soon. Probably soon though.
Uh what do we do? What do we do?
All right. So next one will be
Right. So, we need to do
uh Hang on. Can I do this this way?
because we're going to have different
types of tests. Yeah. Okay. We'll do it
this way.
Okay. So, yeah, we'll just do basically
the entire block repeated.
I have a doc uh the doc I can't share
but let me find I think we discussed uh
some of the tests that I wanted to
include with them.
Let me go find it.
Okay. So, we wanted to test out energy
production.
Yeah. So, there's supposed to be an
energy production spec.
So, let's do that. So, we'll just have
Let me think how that works.
That's kind of janky, isn't it?
I guess it's a good test.
It's a quite good test. So,
Yeah, we'll just do the exact same as
before.
Uh we need to do the prices, don't we?
Oops.
These ones
node capacity energy based demand. Yeah.
So I need to go check how these factor
in and how I want to do this
So we set kilowatt hour price base
and A1 is all we need to set I believe.
Okay. So, energy revenue is 8
89. Cool.
I think we want to change this to be
instead of 100,
uh, let's Say this is going to be a 4day
test.
Well, that's annoying actually because
it doesn't um
Hello, Lass Mutual. Welcome.
Doing a little bit of environment
development.
Ah, but we don't have Hang on. Why is
this one screwing up?
Well, that's actually a pain. Let's
Let's fix that real quick.
Yeah. So, once this end is set, um, I'll
be good for a little bit. Well, not
actually very long. We have
two or possibly three new contracts
starting soon. So, I need to kind of
balance my time between that and um the
puffer for odev.
I really wish I could just like finish,
you know, slam all the kernel dev, have
it done, and then start all these
contracts, but unfortunately, it just it
took me a little longer than I was
expecting. Realistically, it was just
much more complicated than I was
expecting um to get up to 10 mil. And we
still have 1 mil to go. I think within a
few more streams, we'll have we'll
basically have the super jank prototype
of the tech done for Puffer 4 and then
it'll just be a whole bunch of cleaning
up and testing, which that's easier to
do concurrent with client stuff, I'd
say.
Oh, do we have Hang on. Did we screw
something up?
Oh, I see. So there there is a big
problem with this.
Will you still go to college? Yeah,
dude. I was such a dumbass by comparison
at 16 to 17. Like, okay, sure, I was
doing cool stuff for my age, right?
Like, I was doing stuff several years
ahead of my age, but it was still
garbage. It takes a long time to
actually get to be reasonably competent.
And that's still true today. Like today
you have the illusion of competence
because a lot of the tools are much
easier. That doesn't actually mean that
you know what's going on, right? It
takes a long time to actually learn
things at a level that you know what is
going on
like I kind of vaguely remember how
programming felt um before I actually
understood things and it's just like
I mean people think clear writing is
clear thinking. I should try
programming.
Yes, attemp assembly is taught as a
standard in college. Uh, it's not really
taught. The thing is it's kind of it's
introduced too early to where you can't
really appreciate it back then. I'd
actually probably if I were going to go
study anything again, it would probably
be some of the system stuff that I
didn't really understand when it was
introduced.
So it's 100 steps, right? Reset.
Interesting,
Okay, this is expected. And then we do
minus one.
Okay, now it's getting a little awkward.
Um,
oh, well, this is Yeah. Okay, cool.
So, this one passed this.
Learn in college versus on your own.
I mean it's kind of difficult because
like
let me let me tell you why that question
is so awkward. So like technically did I
learn my basic system stuff in college?
Yes.
Did I appreciate it in a way that I was
able to do literally anything at all
with it? No. In fact it was so bad that
I refused to touch anything low-level
for the next nearly decade.
But then when I came back to systems
having spent 10 years programming and 10
years just really caring about how do we
write better faster code even though I
was doing it in totally the wrong
language mostly Python. Um it only took
me three weeks before I was at least as
comfortable if not more comfortable in C
than I was in Python.
Um
and that wasn't because of what they
taught me, right? That was because what
I had learned about how to write good
code over the last decade. So like yes I
remembered ah yes there is a stack there
is a heap I need to allocate memory this
is what a pointer is yada yada sure but
like
the nuts and bolts of it are such a
small component of learning in general
that I'm really not going to give them
much credit.
I I will say that the one nice thing um
about seeing that stuff in a formal
setting is knowing that you're not
missing major chunks of stuff, right?
But even sometimes they even mess that
up, right? Like I remember that I didn't
know what hashing was. So I was using
dictionaries without knowing how the
heck they actually worked uh until I got
to college. But then college also forgot
uh to bother telling us what an address
sanitizer was in our systems courses
which made them absolutely miserable.
Uh, it's totally viable. Nobody's
bothered.
Cool. So, let's figure out the amount of
energy this thing needs.
This unique. Yeah. So, sounds if I were
going to do it, I'd probably not really
bother with the 3D thing. I'd just do
like a top down CS map or something and
see if you can get some really cool
tactical like 5v5 team stuff out of it.
Honestly, there are like so many cool
things though.
Like the fact that RL is so good at
mechanics is really interesting in some
ways. Like aiming isn't that
interesting, right? But if you think of
like uh the mechanics and MMOs, that
stuff is really interesting that RL can
be really good at
then it's more of a parkour. No, no, no,
not parkour game. I mean like the fact
that you have a turning radius, right?
Like you know who sees who first, who's
covering what angle. That stuff would be
really interesting.
Angel investments. No.
What do you mean? Have I done angel
investments or have I taken angel
investments?
Buffer is not big enough that I'd be
doing angel investments and it's doing
well enough that I don't need to take
angel investments,
DDR would be like trivial. But the thing
is that's like obvious button inputs,
right?
I think the ones the games that are
interesting for RL are the ones where
it's kind of difficult to write a good
scripted bot, but at the same time it's
like really easy for the uh RL to just
crush the mechanics.
I don't know. I think probably if I feel
like doing M for the sake of doing M,
I'm probably going to do some more like
MMO bosses.
I I did unfortunately download Runescape
again after seeing oh 25th anniversary
max concurrent players achieved
whatever. And there are just so many
crazy things in that game that are
awesome awesome test environments for
RL.
They're looking at you. Did you actually
play or is it just sitting there looking
at you for now?
Did I actually play RS? Yeah, I play.
I don't bought it.
It's like my favorite game.
Oh, yeah. I [laughter]
Yeah, I've been playing it a bit.
I don't know. I mean, like I hadn't
played it in three years, but I still do
probably have like a top 1% account or
whatever. It's the only game I've ever
like gotten towards the top of the
player base at. And it's really
surprisingly comfortable. Like you can
pick it back up very quickly,
which is cool.
right, we need to get this energy
profile to be something we can test. I
think that's the next play.
For some reason, this says 8.5 almost
exactly.
Doing RL experiments on their own. you
come join the Puffer Discord and you ask
around in there and read the guides.
Like doing RL experiments completely on
your own outside of Puffer, you're not
going to have a fun time.
Like I basically spent the last two plus
years actually making everything work.
If you try to implement a lot of the
stuff from scratch from papers, it's
just not going to work.
Okay, let me see if I have this right.
So, if I set this to one
>> [sighs]
>> All right, somebody tell me the integral
of this. I'm really dumb. Is it one or
is it 2 pi?
It's one, right?
over
or is it 24? No, wait. Is it It's
supposed to be 24, right?
Okay, we're going to look up the
stupidest integral ever because I
haven't done an integral in years.
Oh, you idiot.
You dummy.
Okay, we need to add there has to be a
base price of one.
Yeah. Okay. I'm stupid. It's zero. Duh.
Okay. I forgot to shift it. And then if
you shift it, it'll be Wait, if I shift
it, it's one, right?
One each. Yes. 24.
MIT PhD by the way. What is integral of
cosine?
Dude, if you need to ask the language
model, the integral of cosine, I'd know.
If implementing from scratch doesn't
work, how do I get a deep understanding
of everything? Look, okay, I will be the
first person to tell you to implement
stuff from scratch, implement
environments from scratch, okay? Like,
go look at how the environments are
built in Puffer. follow one of our
guides and build your own environment
completely from scratch. Don't go try to
implement the algorithm from scratch, it
will not work. It takes years to get
these things to be properly stable.
Like if you just even go try anything
outside of Puffer Live, I promise you go
pick any other library and you just try
to run the same experiments that we do,
they will not work.
You'll understand why a little bit more
if you read some of the guides, but
there is totally stuff that you can
implement from scratch that will work
and will be saying, but it's the
environments. Don't try to do the
algorithms. If you go try to just
implement DQN or like, you know, basic
PO or something, it just won't work.
All right, so what do we have here? We
got
from my RL final to your channel
recommended.
Congrats. Congrats. Welcome.
We are touching up this uh commerce
environment
and currently writing a bunch of tests
to see make sure dynamics are correct
and then we'll plug it back into puffer
lip and we will run some crazy
experiments
uh to your channel. If you have not seen
puffer lip and you're doing RL
definitely check the project out. You
can run tons and tons of experiments at
home on your laptop at millions of steps
per second.
Here are some of our demos.
These are all running in your browser.
You can just click any of these. Simple
breakout.
Something way way more complicated.
There's impulse wars. The bots are not
great on this one, but they are there.
All open source.
You want to help out for free?
Feed Whoops.
Feed the puffer a star and get help.
We're almost to 5k.
49. Okay. You know why? Uh this is only
selling revenue. This is only selling
energy over the cap is why.
Yeah, it's only selling energy over the
cap.
Took me a few days to get sacked.
Working on car racing. We weren't
allowed to use libs aside from gym man.
Yeah. So, um, car racing. Here you go.
You can literally train this in seconds,
man. Seconds.
Where is it?
I think this one could use a little bit
more work to be fair. Where's the top
down for this?
Is it uh
somebody added top down for this as
well?
There we go.
Yeah, I think the agent is not amazing
on the website for this. Yeah, it's not
amazing on the website. Um, this was
like a there is a better version of
this, I believe, in the dev branch, but
you can literally train it in seconds.
Yeah. So, for high um high throughput
SIM, SACE is just a really bad
algorithm. Um our stuff is all it's not
exactly PO. It's a fairly advanced
version um from our own research, but
we're able to crank currently 3 million
steps per second on a lot of the
environments. Next version it'll be 10
million. And that means you can learn a
lot of stuff in just seconds which is
really awesome for experiments.
Let's see if this fixes. 96 95 one tick
off.
Why are we one tick off energy revenue?
in that case then I should actually make
it should fix it a little bit.
first puffer empty the other day. Was
surprised how easy and fast everything
was. It's going to get easier and
faster. It just takes work.
I mean, right now, right, most of my
effort is going into the Puffer 4
release, which is just how do we get
everything to train 10 million steps per
second is the big big project right now.
My hope is that actually with Puffer 4,
I'm going to have the performance
categorized so nicely that uh users are
actually going to be able to PR kernel
improvements and stuff that uh make
Puffer even faster. So the goal is we
release 10 million steps per second base
and then one of you guys is going to
actually know how to write proper
kernels and probably send us some PRs.
What kind of envy you want to say?
Pretty much whatever
if you want to like
Oh, his N. Yeah,
Sudoku N. Uh Weston in the uh the
Discord has a Sudoku N as well, I'm
pretty sure.
It's a bit annoying because I do ask
everyone for NFPRs. I do eventually
merge them. I'm just always doing a
million things. But uh ultimately we are
reliant on adding more and more new
interesting MS for research progress.
can I just like
I think I can just do this.
Yeah,
perfect.
And that is 96 rev.
So
if I add
Okay, that's two two reasonable checks,
I'd say.
I'm going to go grab myself a cup of tea
and then we will continue
uh for about another hour I say.
Yeah, we're going to get another hour
in. And if I can just get a couple more
of these checks so we can have some
confidence in this, then that means that
the next session I work on this, we'll
be able to probably start binding the
agents back into this. I'll be right
back.
This is for cloud GPUs. I would be
shocked if any companies actually have
like
hyperl sims like this. This is actually
just unique to Popper.
Nobody has these. If Instacart would
like to have uh one of these though,
we do offer paid simulation development
services,
which is what this is.
This is kind of one of those rare
instances where I can stream it because
um
the client decided to open source this.
So, it's pretty cool
client right here. Archive.
You can go check these out.
Oh, what is this? Hey, look at that.
258k concurrent.
Exactly. Sounds
that was not what I was expecting when
you said cup of tea.
>> Nothing like a nice cup of tea.
I have to refill it constantly
otherwise.
All right. So, let me think what we want
next. So, we've got
I mean, probably it's worth investing um
in a good number of these little tests,
right?
Is it worth testing through the agent
API specifically?
So I'm trying to think if we do the
thing is even if we go through the agent
API
and we can probably just do one nice
negotiation fast
Yep,
we'll do it that way.
So,
AI sellers scripted sellers. So we have
to do
M.A.I. sellers zero.
AI buyers be zero.
Oh no wait it's one and one.
Subscripted sellers, scripted buyers
Oh, do I have Hang on. Did I tell him I
would get him a specific API in this?
Oh.
That's full.
I can't handle that much caffeine. This
is literally one tea bag, dude.
I actually I do this because I've had
too much caffeine lately. So, this
actually just gets me to moderate it.
It's just a very large cup of weak tea.
The morning mug though is pretty good.
the morning mug recipe. The uh the first
one of the day. The current recipe is
two scoops of protein powder, two
teaspoons of cocoa, um what is it? A
dash of cinnamon, and a shot of espresso
with two cups of whole milk. You end up
getting a 66 g of protein hot chocolate.
I highly recommend that one.
No,
no protein tea. protein. Hot chocolate.
Good though.
Okay. So, the trick here is just really
going to be figuring out the actions,
right?
Really just the price mall
two times request index
Where did my cursor just go?
How How did I do that? What?
Morning. Snowfall. Snows.
I don't know. Morning snow.
Huh?
We literally just looked at this, didn't
we?
Oh, I see.
Uh, that's interesting.
Yeah, you have this in cents or some
[ __ ] right?
That's wrong.
And I believe uh we We need to do this
weird check, right? Because integers
integers we should be able to represent
cleanly, right?
No.
All right, fine. We'll do the fuzzy
check.
I was right.
It's the one at the bottom.
Failed the bilateral check. Good.
All right. So,
we got some nice test packs in here.
And we even have um we got the bilateral
in here. Perfect.
So, all we got to do is figure out
bilateral negotiation and we'll be good.
Will you be hiring video editors for the
announcement video?
Uh yeah, I'm definitely going to do that
again. I have I probably will just use
the guy that I used before cuz last time
I hired like I hired and paid I believe
four different people. I hired like a
couple cheap video editors. One like
mediumric video editor and one like
fairly expensive video editor. And um I
mean the guy I paid the most to just did
the best job by far. So,
actually the thing that I'm way more
interested in is uh I have a project in
mind where I want to get the puffer the
puffer mascot retouched. I want to get
the model remade to look pretty much the
same as it does now, but actually have
it rigged correctly and everything. Um,
and I want to get a number of animations
made. So, I have like a decent little
animation project, probably a few
thousand dollar budget that I'm going to
need to find somebody for that one. I'm
going to make sure I get somebody good,
though. Like, I'm going to make sure I
get somebody who has done um like low
poly character design and animation. No,
I did not make the little puffer myself.
Are you kidding me? That took like
several hundred messages back and forth
between two different artists.
Okay. So now we have this is the last
test we need for now I think.
Uh let's see what we want to get out of
this
job revenue
800.
So we want to get a th000 revenue out of
this thing.
I think we have some weirdness with the
action space.
I think it's this.
Yeah, there we go. I have the action
space indexed wrong, aren't we?
Cool.
Now, we have revenue, we have expense,
but we want to do something with
negotiation.
We want to do something with
So, this is the seller. The seller is
going to go high.
The buyers go
Okay, that still is expected. But now
this doesn't give us much to test. So I
think we're going to do seller offers
5% discount.
I think that matches, right?
Yeah,
there's a 5% discount.
This is the seller.
Seller should be in 950.
Oh, this is the wait. This is the
seller. So, this is buyer.
Seller.
There you go.
Now we have some nice tests.
I'll make a quick commit and then we can
figure out if we need any other tests.
Um, but this is a solid solid starting
point. We probably should have like a
energy sale or something test. A few
other things.
Let me go let the uh client know that we
have some test passing for him.
There we go.
Okay. Um,
I want to think about if there are any
other tests we need before we start
trying to do the agent stuff.
My goal would be if we can just start on
the next time I do a block of work on
this. If we can just start doing the
agent stuff, that would be ideal.
We actually do have um agents from the
earlier versions, by the way. It works
great. It's just um you know, the new
version that we don't have agents on.
What type of stuff is going to break?
So, you got the basics. So, water
filling.
I kind of want to like extend this test
over many episodes maybe.
Let's Let's just actually It's 10 10
a.m.
and I could just like get the binds like
fixed up real quick. No.
Yeah, this is one of those super
obnoxious binding things that I got to
improve in Puffer 4.
Let's go check the original.
See what we've got.
got the num agents. We got the episode
length,
request timeout,
job duration, job duration, DR
job efficiency? Where is it? Job
duration.
DB usage like this
uh job nodes as well is up there. Of
course,
I actually I find it very important to
like spend the time to do this manually
to have stuff structured
like semantic grouping is so important.
You don't need um
you don't need a code auto formatter.
You don't need a huge style guide. You
just need to do basic semantic grouping
manually.
All right,
that looks good. Now, let's take a look
at the cluster specs.
We can do this will be
cluster node capacity cluster node
capacity
and that is everything with
capacity and that is everything with this
this
buyer spec.
We don't need this either. We just get
rid of this
See, this is like the thing where
I hate having to have things in four
places,
but like it's a language barrier thing,
right? because I have so I have the
strruct okay and C doesn't have defaults
for strrus so I could have like a create
method or whatever that uh that provides
defaults so I have it in two places
um and I could have just be in two
places if it were saved but then you
have the binding file here so that's
three places uh if you want the defaults
in the Python file so you can create it
as a standalone that's four places and
then if you want the default in in your
config file. Then now that's five
places.
So
eh annoying.
Actually, I I think I am just going to
do watch this. We'll do here.
Just do it like this for now.
This will be much less of a pain in the
ass
So, we can grab the old parameter pretty
much from here, right?
Space. All these got copied correctly.
Very good.
Yep.
Not bad.
missing kilowatt hour. Okay, hang on one
second folks.
Okay. Um,
I just have to add these last couple
pars.
Oops. Try this.
Missing required.
Try again
electronic stuff. I've done a couple
things. 24. Not very much.
And no food. GPS. Lovely.
Probably hangs right.
We'll fix that later though. At least we
got the bindings added.
Perfect.
Okay, that is a nice 2 and 1/2 hour
block of work done on this environment
this morning. Um, let me see if we have
any messages. Nope. So, uh, the next
time I do this, we will
probably be able to get the agents
training again. That will be the hope.
Um,
this environment here has been open
sourced by one of our clients.
You can check it out. Right.
There you are. Uh, so this is the new
version of it that I'm working on. It's
open source, so I figured I may as well
stream it. you'll give them a follow if
you want to check out cool high
performance commerce sims for RL and
what they're building on top of that.
Other than that,
5 to 10% science.
Basic science means like coming up with
hypotheses, coming up with experiments
to test them, and then not screwing up
that process along the way such that
your experiments aren't actually
designed to test the thing that you
think or are not actually valid. Just
basic scientific training.
Um,
it sounds simple, but you'd be surprised
the percentage of papers and like
published papers that just mess up the
very, very basics. A lot of what I do is
just doing the basics. Well,
okay. So, for everyone else watching,
I'm going to the gym soon. So, uh, if
you are interested in my stuff
generally, check out puffer.ai. It's all
open source. You can help us out for
absolutely free by starring the GitHub.
Feed the puffer star. We're almost at
5,000. You can join the Discord to get
involved with dev. Most of which is just
building sims and uh plugging stuff into
RL.
It's a good way to get involved. Many of
these are built by contributors.
Good way to learn some low-level debt as
well. And you can follow me on X for
more RL content as well. I will be back
maybe tonight, but definitely tomorrow.
And uh I've got to have another like
long kernel dev session probably
tomorrow. That's going to be the plan.
We're going to see if we can finally hit
10 mil.